what are you doing later what's your
address you like that Dorf years what
year go eat some walruses or missus
porridges morphia dwarf years go get set
up okay Horace's in the past Hillary's
flip-flopped on a few key issues but I
thought overall performance was totally
penas hmm
I do agree that she was totally penis
but is she penis enough to be the
Democratic nominee I mean you have to
admit that Bernie Sanders is taking away
some of Hillary's penis Thunder Paul you
a cool guy but just so you know unless
you put the word totally in front of
penis you're literally talking about
dicks oh my god the smell dude it's bad
hey Kristin I could take you to a place
where it doesn't smell like this
I'm good hey what's up this adjacency go
to start a movie let me check hey what's
up everybody
[Laughter]
what if Jesus was young jeezy
this is Jeezy young yes Jesus hey y'all
some real [ __ ] for this [ __ ] right
[Applause]
[Music]
it's Jesus if you swim past a shark why
they have a sense where they attack I
guess oh man but you know just keep
people keep boning that's right is that
your message to America that is my one
was one of my messages to America heat
Bonin and the other one is if you have
triplets give one away put that thing
down
I'll have my Drake impersonation okay I
went in Toronto I went to Atlanta I used
to drink Pepsi but now I like Fanta view
that God the founder of tinder upset
what did you say I said what tender was
what people like to use it to have
location-based sex
yeah people use your app to bone
strangers this is that you're actually
looking at where the accident yeah I'm
right there
I'm like wow y'all y'all so relaxed you
lives into waka flocka at all is that a
band or a song that's a man yeah no I
think I do
yeah basically like waka flocka yeah
Flaco Flaco ha [ __ ]
stank [ __ ] what the [ __ ] Bank [ __ ]
comedy kamisato what is coming sorry I'm
asado means a military attack that
occurs at night oh yeah like a sneak
surprise attack yeah that's a great word
yeah so why are you calling it the
comedy commissar oh there's gonna be
sneak attacks like a joke that starts
out about fresh-pressed juice might turn
into something about anal sex very
honestly I want to ask you a question
soon when they said hey we've got a
movie about adults playing tag what was
your initial reaction how much does it
pay
no I mean awful shame I don't know your
office I'm trying to get in better shape
my girlfriend she's in good shape she
gives me health tips sometimes like
Hannibal you're gonna die stuff like
that you know that's it
excellent health tip that's it I took a
kickboxing class you ever take a class
with a bunch of people I can't be in
class David Letterman yeah yeah that's
right I didn't take the tag off I'm
taking this back tomorrow I just bought
this for yourself
[Applause]
Beckett that's Excel that's Excel yeah
four hundred and twenty five dollars
that's too much money for a jacket oh
I'd still wanted to be a part of the
premier so I I hired somebody to go for
me you put this tweet up and the tweet
says la I need to look alike with solid
comedic timing for an event tonight pay
$500 and it yeah email do Hannibal look
look-alike three at gmail.com so when
you're in Chicago yeah you're a big New
York everybody did it's Chicago chances
on tour now
football players I've held with so their
net famous baseball players have 200
games so they're busy so basically is
like me and John Cusack so how many
males did you get one hundred hundreds
okay and some from from white people
they were wasting my time white dudes
from Portland you send me a picture look
like wasting my time you have to get
help me progress I did I did what do you
what are you eating now I have popcorn
you got this Nazi but a pot you put
popcorn in your chat your breast pocket
radicals the huge universe like this you
know it was a great opportunity I had a
lot of fun
funny is huge you know we grow up
watching spider-man so the play coach
Wilson working with the cast was the
great time whatever I eat at a
restaurant I never put the napkin in my
lap I never put the napkin in my lap and
people say Hannibal why don't you put
the napkin in your lap because I believe
in myself and my mama raised me to have
confidence and my brothers taught me how
to fight and I just feel good and also
your bitch-ass [ __ ] Hey
[Music]